welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and Thor love and thunder
introduces who is being described as the
mcu's most fearsome villain yet
Christian Bale's Gore the god Butcher
and while we've talked a lot about this
guy's appearance and how he seems to be
a harbinger of gray tone in this film
one specific visual detail Within
trailer footage hasn't really been
explored enough the fact that in some
shots of the trailer when he stands
amidst a lush colorful world he looks
more like bald pale skin Christian Bale
with yellow orange eyes and linear
tattoos on either side of his head but
in other shots the tattoos have been
covered by Scar Tissue lumpy cross
hatches forming interesting lines and
trenches on his furrowed brow as Inky
blood oozes from his mouth in fact and
this gives me nightmares the shot of
Gore pushing through the thorny Bramble
when you look at it in 4k and brighten
it a bit you can see Gore's dim eyes his
skull-like nostrils and faint teeth
looming through the Merc it's extremely
unsettling at first I thought these
might just be wounds that Gore endured
from his battles with Thor and Jane
Valkyrie but no no the scarring is
exactly along the lines of those tattoos
as if he scarred himself to cover those
tattoos in a specific way in some kind
of ritualistic practice or what was
there previously might have represented
something inside of him that he
extracted to untether him from his
restraints to his past so how do we
explain Gore's transformation throughout
this film what causes this physical
erosion let's start with everything Gore
has said and done so far in the footage
in the main trailer we heard him say the
only ones who Gods care about is
themselves so This Is My Vow oh God he
also tells Thor you I'm not the other
guy
because I have something worth fighting
for we see the more Christian Bailey
looking Gore on this Lush Planet another
with his hands slowly clutching his
sword on a coastline then a shot of Gore
pushing through some of those gray toned
Vines and then lowering his hood to show
his new yucky status another one of him
gasping or Screaming as something pointy
lowers in frame in the foreground and
then a shot of him plunging his sword
into this Rocky surface then a wide shot
that may be connected to that or part of
a different scene but blue mjolnir style
lightning bolts exploding out from a
moon because I don't see an atmosphere
on this planet and cracking it all to
bits and then on this same broken
surface Gore fighting against Thor and
Valkyrie as color drains from Valkyrie
making her black and white the closer
she gets to him and then him pointing at
Thor in this setting another shot of
Thor and Jane's fingers interlocking as
they walk towards something or someone
in this same place but there's also this
new line from a recent promo
and since we are in MCU Cosmos filled
with planets and worlds which singular
world is Gore now referring to he might
just be using the term world as a
general term as in like all of reality
we'll be better off Godless but the fact
that an MCU Planet Hopper like this
talks this way tells us that he is in a
pretty limited Place psychologically
like he doesn't care about the cosmos as
a whole you can only see as far as his
current Horizon that I think is a
context that he is saying this
particular line but also we got to
remember Gore uses the term vow which
tells us that he views his mission to
eradicate Gods with a kind of religious
zealotry something that he has in common
with Thanos that I'll explain a little
bit later in this video but in this case
might tell us something about his
scarring this man is mourning and for
many MCU characters scarring and Tattoos
like this tells us something about their
pasts obviously for killmonger his
ritualistic scarring represented each of
his kills in the case of Drax and
Guardians of the Galaxy James Gunn
actually explained at one point on
Instagram drax's tattoos are not about
his conquests but about the memories he
has with this family and how appropriate
is it then that Thor in this film when
Zeus flicks off his clothes reveals how
he has Inked his skin with family
University is lost Loki's horned crown
with the letters R.I.P Loki so for Gore
the scar is now etched on the sides of
his forehead where those stripes once
were might be his attempt to do the same
to cover the basic tattoos that once
bound him to his home world a world that
no longer exists because the gods failed
to save him and instead scar himself to
memorialize his dead wife whose name was
ARA and his children last surviving one
was named agar a kid who eventually
starved to death so these scars that we
see on Gore's head might not be random
cross hatches and lines but rather
specific markings maybe in his native
cuneiform or Marquis in some other way
to represent the names of his wife and
children R.I.P ARA R.I.P agar Etc now in
the next few months we're gonna get new
Game of Thrones and Lord of the Rings
series and now would be an awesome time
to dive into those amazing books or
enjoy them all over again in a new
format and you can do that on Audible
the sponsor of this video you can even
hear The Fellowship of the Ring narrated
by Gollum himself Andy Circus audible
offers and incredible selection of
audiobooks across every genre from
bestsellers and new releases to
celebrity Memoirs Mysteries and
thrillers motivation and more you'll
also discover exclusive audible
originals from top celebrities renowned
experts and exciting new voices in audio
as an audible member you can choose one
title a month to keep from their entire
catalog including the latest bestsellers
in new releases all audible members now
also get access to a growing selection
of titles included with membership that
you can listen to all you want the
selection includes audiobooks audible
originals and podcasts more get added
every month the audible app makes it
easy to listen anytime anywhere have it
on your phone and you can listen while
traveling doing chores or climbing Mount
Doom new members can try audible free
for 30 days visit audible.com new
rockstars or text new rockstars to 500
500. now any number of apocalyptic
events could have led to the deaths of
Gore's family like the birth of a
Celestial as I have speculated the
centuries six mentioned in eternals
might have been a past neighbor to
Centauri 4 that we see in trailer
footage and that planet's Horizon
containing the ashes and space debris of
Gore's home world and a Celestial
hatched out of remember there's also
egos near assimilation of the universe
goo that certainly smothered thousands
across the cosmos before it was stopped
we don't really talk about that of
course thanos's Conquest blipped half of
all life from the universe and even when
those Souls were returned they came back
to an extremely chaotic life in agora's
case he might have come back to find
that his family had died in his absence
all of these events can be traced back
to celestials and or eternals either way
Gods but we may also learn that Gore is
far older as he is in the comics like
Jason Aaron's Comics show how Gore
traveled the cosmos for thousands of
years murdering Gods before Thor comes
into his crosshairs and in the MCU we do
have the ancient severed head of the
celestial nowhere when the comics was
beheaded by the same sword that Gore now
carries all black the necrosword but in
that instance was wielded by a different
person no the Symbiote deity and since
of course Sony owns the rights to all
the Symbiotes including Venom Carnage
Etc I don't know know if that will
connect in this particular way in the
MCU but what I like about that Century 6
theory is that planet's destruction must
not have been recent as this was the
same group of eternals who helped
oversee its destruction and they have
been on Earth for 7 000 years so that
theory were true Gore would have to be
over 7000 years old far older than Thor
or any of these characters and what
intrigues me about this new line from
Gore the world will be better without
Gods is that he might be referring to a
new planet that he wants to build
completely free from any Divine
oversight or Godly jurisdiction a
god-free world this would mean that Gore
is less of a self-destructive Kamikaze
force and more someone like Thanos who
was also a religious zealot but a
revolutionary hoping to burn everything
down to build something new and that
could explain the desaturation we see
the universe of Technicolor that we know
is provided by celestials gods and
infinity stone radiation coursing
through everything that is what gives
our world its color and without those
gods and without those stones we would
just be full grayscale and this could be
a choice that Jane faces in this movie
Why Jane is so important to this plot
trailer footage has not shown it yet
which I find interesting but Jane Foster
has cancer in the story there are a few
ways she could have gotten it but
chances are her experiences with gods
and with infinity stone radiation did
not help literally her helping Gods left
her with a curse my theory is that some
of the cosmic entities might have taken
pity on her like the Living Tribunal
infinity and maybe offered her a
temporary Escape in the form of this
Godly promotion but in the comics those
power-ups The Mighty Thor are not a
permanent cure they just delay and reset
her chemo whenever she reverts to James
so Gore's Godless stoneless radiation
less world may give Jane a true reset
and why we only see Thor and Jane in
this setting from behind with their
fingers interlocked as if they're
accepting their fate here it could be an
escape that Jane actually considers and
you know what should be totally right
too but I want to know your thoughts on
these theories in the comments below
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at
eavos follow new Rockstar subscribe to
new rockstars more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
thank you